too many of the women I think have
emotional responses and we become
defensive because of our history because
of what we've been through in the past
and we get triggered and rather than
allow someone to speak and hear the full
length of what they have to say where
maybe we can learn something and take
something on board it might hurt
triggered but that doesn't mean what he
had to say might not have made some
sense I say might not because I didn't
hear it okay let me just check on just
one thing because I'm not against you
okay but I'm not against him either as
women we need to get to understand
masculine energy it's not a negative
because it's louder or stronger or more
assertive that's what massiveness we are
the opposite we are feminine and
sometimes we have to learn
how to allow that